et on va pouvoir rejoindre donc la
gauche qui est réunie place des
Invalides pour un cordon républicain
face au rassemblement national on écoute
marine tonier pour toute la semaine
évidemment que c'est désastreux d'avoir
des polémiques sur ce genre de sujet qui
devrait nous rassembler évidemment que
la participation du rassemblement
national à ses marches trouble
énormément et nous-mêmes nous sommes
troublés c'est pas un plaisir que de
participer au même rassemblement surtout
sur ce sujet évidemment mais il nous
semblait que notre place était ici
et que la descence le respect les aurait
invité eux à ne pas venir le
rassemblement national est un parti qui
a été fondé par des VAF SS dont le
président a encore dit dimanche dernier
que Jean-Marie Le Pen n'avait pas de
problème avec l'antisémitisme alors
qu'il a quand même été condamné
plusieurs fois pour négationnisme
reconquête est un parti dont le
président Éric Zemour a été condamné
plusieurs fois aussi pour un je racial
c'est chez chez eux ils appelleraient ça
du multirécidivisme donc ils sont en
fait les spécialistes et donc oui c'est
très déstab isant d'avoir à marcher dans
la même manifestation queeux c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous ne voulions
pas leur laisser la place ce n'était pas
à nous de partir c'était à eux et donc
nous avons organisé avec le Parti
communiste avec le Parti socialiste avec
beaucoup de partis politiques qui nous
ont rejoint avec aussi des associatif
j'envoie à mes côtés d'ailleurs vous
pourriez laisser une petite place au
président de l'ldh qui est étouffé par
le service d' et donc voilà nous sommes
nombreux aujourd'hui on est très fier de
participer à cette marche on est très
fier d'organiser notre propre cortège
contre contre l'antisémitisme et toutes
les formes il y a un problème vous avez
l'air très donc on est très fier
d'organiser ce cortège contre
l'antisémitisme et contre toutes les
formes de haine et de racisme je pense
que le message est clair beaucoup de
d'habitants de républicains de militants
de citoyens avaient envie de pouvoir
venir à cette marche sans mettre les
leurs pas dans les pas du rassemblement
national le cortège que nous avons
organisé va le leur permettre et je
pense que c'est salutaire VO notre
présence